- Good morning everyone.
Welcome, this is SEC316.
I am Rick Anthony,
I'm a senior manager for
the Amazon inspection team.
I'm here with Anthony and Nirali.
They'll be speaking to you later.
And we're gonna talk to
you about Amazon Inspector
and strategies for
vulnerability management.
So quick agenda for this morning,
we're gonna talk about
some of the challenges
of traditional vulnerability management.
We're gonna talk about
what is Amazon Inspector,
how does it work, what are
some of the key capabilities,
show you a couple of
demos, and talk to you
about one of our newer
features, code security.
So first, challenges with traditional
vulnerability management.
A lot of traditional solutions
haven't been built for the cloud.
And one of the superpowers of the cloud
is that it's elastic.
Resources can be scaled up,
they can be scaled down
to meet your needs.
And there's a lot of
different types of compute
that you can use as a customer.
You can use virtual machines,
you can use containers,
you can use serverless,
and you want to be able
to cover all of those
with your solution.
And so some of the environments
that your developers are gonna create
can be really complex
and that really also leads
into some resource constraints.
How do you know what
resources are out there
and running if they're
going to be that dynamic?
Some of the traditional solutions
also ask you to license
each of your resources.
Well, how do you do that
when all of your resources
are going up and down together?
How are you also ensuring
that you're seeing all of them
if you're only scanning periodically?
Once you do scan,
you end up with a lot of findings.
And if you scan on Monday,
you generate a thousand findings.
You scan again on Tuesday,
you have another thousand.
How do you deal with all those?
How do you prioritize the
findings that you're getting?
You could use some simple methods.
You could look at the severity,
start with the criticals,
but more and more,
there are a lot of critical
vulnerabilities out there
and they may not be the
most important ones for you
to remediate based off
of your environment.
So this is where Amazon
Inspector comes in.
We launched Amazon Inspector
a couple of years ago,
and we created Amazon Inspector
to be an automated
vulnerability management service
that continually monitors your workloads
for software vulnerabilities
and unintended network exposures.
And you can see that we've highlighted
two really key features
of Inspector right here.
One is automated.
And what this means is that
once you enable Inspector
and configure it, it does
all the work for you.
You don't have to manage it.
You don't have to tell it what to do.
Number two, it continually
scans your resources.
So in that dynamic cloud environment,
as resources come up,
Inspector sees them, it scans them,
and as resources goes
down, Amazon sees that
and will automatically
close findings for you.
You don't have to manage
the service for you,
it does it.
Our goal is for you to
worry about remediation
and taking action,
and that's it.
So when we launched Amazon Inspector,
we launched it with support
for virtual machines through Amazon EC2,
container images through Amazon ECR,
and then we added support
for serverless functions
through AWS Lambda.
And then most recently this year,
we also support manage code repositories
through our interactions
and interfaces to GitHub and GitLab.
So really a quick overview
of Amazon Inspector.
When we talk about Amazon Inspector
and how you use it,
we really talk about
four different phases.
Phase one is enablement.
And this is, as a customer,
you going in and turning
Amazon Inspector on
either for your account
or for your entire organization.
You can do both.
Second, once you do that,
Amazon Inspector will start
looking at your environment.
It will discover all your resources
and scan those resources
to get a initial set of findings
so that you know where you are from
in terms of your exposures
and then it'll start monitoring.
So as changes take place,
Amazon Inspector follows suit.
Third phase is looking at your findings.
Inspector will contextualize your findings
so that you can prioritize
what's important.
Severity is not the only critical thing.
Some of your resources are exposed
to the internet, some of them are not.
Some of them have vulnerabilities
that can be exploited,
some of them don't.
Inspector takes a lot of different pieces
of information together to
give you a prioritization score
that you can use to take action.
And taking action is our fourth phase
where once you have your findings,
where do you want to do your work?
You can do your work in Inspector,
you can do it in Security Hub.
We give you lots of different options.
We're gonna dig into each
one of these quickly.
So number one, like I said,
when you turn on Amazon Inspector,
you can enable it for your account
or you can enable it for
your entire organization.
We see most of our customers
turning on Inspector
for their entire organization.
What they do is they use
their management account
to assign a delegated administrator.
And from that delegated
administrator account,
they can tell Amazon
Inspector what to scan
and based on what settings.
And we also provide you a way
of automatically enabling Inspector
for all new accounts added
to your organization.
And the power of that is
once you get it set up,
if you say turn it on
for all new accounts,
you no longer have to worry
about having gaps in coverage.
Inspector will enable
itself automatically.
Secondly, that delegated
administrator account,
not only does it configure
your entire organization,
it also has visibility into
your entire organization.
So as a user within the
delegated administrator account,
you have a centralized view
of all your findings
regardless of the account.
As a customer,
you can manage all your
findings for your organization
from that one view while
your individual accounts
still have visibility
into their own findings.
So if you cut a ticket to
one of your teams saying,
hey, you have this vulnerability,
they can go in Inspector,
they'll see the exact same details
that the delegated administrator sees.
We launched with this capability
when Inspector launched
a couple years ago,
and we also upgraded that capability
to do an organization
configuration enablement
through support for organization policies
that just launched this year.
Phase two is the discover,
scan and monitor phase.
And this is where Amazon
Inspector, when you turn it on,
it sees all of your resources.
So if you ever want to know
what are your accounts running,
what are the resources,
what do they look like,
Amazon Inspector knows.
It sees these resources as they launch,
it sees these resources as they terminate
and it updates accordingly.
Like I said before, we
support EC2 instances,
container images and ECR, Lambda functions
and now manage code repositories.
Inspector works in near real time.
So that as changes occur,
you get those findings right away.
Amazon Inspector is also intelligent.
We talked about one of the challenges
of traditional vulnerability management
where you, as a customer, have to decide
when you're going to scan.
You don't know if you're
catching everything.
Here, Inspector monitors your environment
and scans when it needs to scan.
If a new resource is launched,
Amazon Inspector scans it.
If you install a new software
package on a resource,
Amazon Inspector scans it.
If you patch, Amazon Inspector
sees that patch, rescans
and the findings for
vulnerability are now remediated,
it will close those findings.
If there's a new CVE published,
Amazon Inspector knows
which of your resources have that package
and will automatically re-scan.
So that at any point in time,
you can go to Amazon Inspector know
what is your security posture
at that moment in time.
You don't have to do
any work to get there.
And then phase three is contextualization
of those findings.
Amazon Inspector supports
what we call the Amazon Inspector Score,
and this tries to answer
a whole bunch of questions that you have.
One question may be: what is
the most severe vulnerability
that I need to remediate?
Is it for a resource that's exposed?
Does that vulnerability have a exploit?
Is that exploit common in a wild?
Amazon uses all that information
in order to score up or score
down your vulnerabilities.
So that when you look at
Amazon Inspector's score,
you're truly looking at
the most important things
for you to fix within your environment.
We do this using a bunch of advanced
vulnerability intelligence information
that we partner with
Recorded Future to gather.
So as a security professional,
you can go in and see,
okay, this vulnerability,
how is it mapped to MITRE ATT&CK TTPs?
Is there a known CISA exploit?
Is it there a malware kit for it?
Is this commonly exploited in the wild
so that you can double check our work
and make your own decisions as well
as to what you wanna remediate first?
We package all of our
vulnerability information
into a format
where you can search it for yourself.
You can look at CVEs, you can know,
okay, does Inspector know about the CVE?
What are the details?
Is it a high?
Is it a low?
I can check to see what type
of resources it impacts.
And I can also immediately know
which of my resources
are impacted by this.
A couple of years ago,
we did a talk very similar to this talk
where we had a customer join us
from Volkswagen Financial Services.
They are a user of Inspector
and the speaker, Crispin talked about
having a call from his boss
on a Monday morning as
he was commuting to work.
His boss said, "Hey, I just read about
this brand new Windows vulnerability.
Looks pretty severe.
Are we impacted?"
And so Crispin said that
sitting at his desk,
he was able to go into Inspector,
type the number of the CVE,
see that Inspector supported it.
And because Inspector had
already all of his resources,
'cause this is done
dynamically in near real time,
he was able to identify every account
and every resource that had an impact
and was able to email a
note out to all those owners
to do a remediation within 14 minutes
because all the information was fresh
and it was at his fingertips.
That's the power of near real time
and always knowing what your posture is.
One of the new pieces of information
that Inspector reports on,
which we're really proud of
and we're excited to talk about,
is near real time malicious
package detection.
So through a partnership with the OpenSSF,
we now pull in malicious
package information
and we use that in order to determine
do you have packages that are malicious?
Are these going to cause some unknown
or unwanted behavior within your account?
Not only are we using the
information from OpenSSF,
we are con contributing as well.
In fact, right now we are one
of the largest contributors.
Earlier this year, we started
scanning NPM registries
and through a set of our own
specialized detection rules
that are a combination of
static/dynamic AI rules,
we are able in near real time
to detect malicious packages.
We post this to OpenSSF,
they assign a malware ID.
We put this into Inspector immediately
and we begin reporting on this
within your own environments.
We published a blog a couple of weeks ago
where using these techniques,
we found one of the largest campaigns
to do tokenization farming
what we think ever occurred.
So we detected over
150,000 malicious packages
in NPM registries.
It's a great blog article.
I encourage you to go out and read it.
We're really excited about this program
and this is something
that we're going to expand
into other forms as registries.
So really, let me spend a couple minutes
to give you a quick demo
of how this would work.
All right, so one of
our security researchers
put together a docker file
where he installed a
known malicious package.
It's that one called anhackle/test.
And as a note, please don't repeat this,
this is actually a real malicious package.
He built the docker file.
He pushed it into the ECR registry.
ECR is one of the formats
that Inspector supports.
Here you can see within this account
we have Amazon Inspector running.
We have scanning for ECR enabled.
This is the repository
where the file was pushed.
And here you can see we've detected
that malware package
automatically in near real time.
Obviously, we've accelerated
this for today's demo,
but along with the information
for this malware finding,
you can see we've detected
other CVEs as well.
And as a customer there's a
lot of different information
we provide you.
So you can either feed
it into other systems
or just go in and look at it yourself.
Here you can see this has
an Inspector score of 9.8.
It's sourced from OSSF.
This is something we detected
the version of the package
and where this package lives.
And if you want to look
up more information,
we give you a reference so you can go back
and see that this was
truly a malicious package
published by OSSF.
And here this is credited
to Amazon Inspector as the finding.
Okay, and then finally our fourth phase
of using Amazon Inspector is
taking action with findings.
So within Amazon Inspector,
using that delegated
administrator account,
you see the findings for
your entire organization.
You can operate directly
within Amazon Inspector.
You could send your
findings into Security Hub
as another one of our tools
to help you focus on
your remediation efforts.
But you have other options as well.
We send our findings out to EventBridge
so you can hook those
up into other systems
using Lambda functions.
You can have partner applications
that pull into this data
or you can look at it in some
of our other services as well.
As an example, Amazon ECR
also will show findings
for your container images.
And then finally,
as a last way of looking at your data
and taking action is
software bill of materials.
So Amazon Inspector, at any point in time,
you can say to Inspector,
please export SBOM for my environment.
And you can choose your
account, your organization,
you can filter the data any way you want.
We support SBOM in CycloneDx format.
We support it in SPDX format.
And once you have that data,
there's all different ways
you can slice and dice it.
You could send it into Amazon Athena
to do different types of queries
or you could send it into QuickSight.
Lots of different ways.
That SBOM data is free of charge
and you can do whatever you want with it.
All right, I'm gonna hand off to Anthony
and he's gonna talk about
some of the other capabilities
of Amazon Inspector.
Thank you.
- Thank you, Rick.
Can everyone hear me okay?
Great.
My name is Anthony.
I'm a product manager in Inspector.
I work closely with Rick and Nirali.
And my purpose of this section
is to give you an overview of actually
how do you, as a customer,
go about using Inspector as a product
to meet those effective
vulnerability management use cases
that Rick talked about.
And hopefully, as an
objective of this section
of the presentation, you
have a deeper understanding
of actually how to use Inspector
to go start this journey
of setting up Inspector and
working through these problems.
A quick pull of hands,
how many of you're already
using Amazon Inspector?
Okay, great.
So quite a few people there to learn about
how to set this up and use this product.
So before I get going,
I just wanted to touch
on sort of where we are
in the overall like
life cycle of developing
and launching products
and managing software vulnerabilities.
And the section that
I'm gonna focus on here
is really monitor and respond
as well as some components
of build and test.
So the core capabilities of
Inspectors really monitoring
and providing you that visibility,
near time visibility on those
resources and those findings
so that you have an accurate understanding
of your security posture.
But as a customer, what
you really wanna do
is start shifting left,
but I'm gonna focus here a little bit more
on what we do today to help you
in this monitor and respond area.
This slide is gonna be sort of our map,
which is just gonna kind of help guide
all the capabilities I'm
gonna talk to you about
and it's gonna help just orient you
as we go section by
section on each of these.
So as a metal model,
there's really two different
sort of groups of capabilities
as I like to think of them.
For Inspector, there's
continuous monitoring,
which is providing that
real time visibility
into those resources.
And that covers EC2 Lambda and ECR images.
And then we have some
additional utility capabilities,
I call 'em ad hoc, which
include managing SBOM,
some of that is what Rick talked about,
CIS benchmark scanning.
And then we also have some other tools
that help you shift left
in build and deploy.
Before I get started with that,
I wanted to just take a second to talk
and underline the importance
of continuous scanning.
So the purpose of continuous scanning
is that essentially as the days go by
and you're doing your day job,
the goalposts are always
moving in security.
So I have this very simple illustration
of just why that's important
in terms of why scanning today, tomorrow,
and two days from now
helps you understand, as a customer,
when you need to take action or not.
So we can imagine a scenario
where on the 1st of January,
you have 10 packages
that Inspector is detecting,
Inspector is not finding any
packages associated with a CVE
and therefore it's not
cutting any findings.
We can imagine 10 days
later on January 10th,
there is a new CVE
published for a package.
But that package is not in
something like let's say
your ECR container image.
But on the 15th of there's
a new CVE published
and we actually do observe as we scan
that that package is associated
with a vulnerability.
And at that moment, we're
gonna cut a finding to you
and you're gonna have a
finding which you can choose
to react to or not react to
depending on your risk appetite.
So this is really important
just to illustrate the fact
that it's an ongoing job
that you have to understand
your security posture
and the information that
Inspector provides you
is informing what you, as a customer,
need to do to take action
to secure your environment.
And I'm gonna go ahead
and jump to EC2 scanning.
So I'll go EC2 scanning
Lambda, ECR image scanning
and then I'll touch ad hoc functionality.
So there's a few key points
to understand about Amazon EC2 scanning.
An EC2 instance is
obviously a virtual machine
and one of the key decisions
that you have to make as a customer,
and hopefully you'll
be making this decision
as that Inspector delegated administrator
across your entire organization,
is what kind of scanning mode
do you want to implement
across your environment?
So there's two different modes
that you, as a customer,
have the choice to choose.
You have an agent based approach
which uses the AWS systems
manager agent, the SSM agent.
We like to use the term to
describe it as ubiquitous
and it's meant to be as easy as possible
to install across your fleet.
When the SSM agent is installed
and operating correctly on an EC2 instance
and you enable EC2 scanning,
Inspector will use the SSM agent
and a small piece of
technology that we have
to go actually execute
those scans, do the work,
and then cut the findings to you
via the Inspector service.
There are some capabilities
within systems manager
that you can also leverage
to have a full view across
your entire AWS organization
for every single EC2 instance
that's gonna tell you
whether every single EC2 instance
is being managed by the SSM agent.
If not, why not?
And there's also some tools
that help you diagnose
and remediate common
operational issues with that.
Now we have a second scanning mode,
which we call hybrid,
which came after our agent-based approach.
And this is actually what we
most recommend to customers
and is the default
experience for new customers.
In the hybrid experience,
we are gonna be scanning
using the SSM agent
in the agent-based approach.
If the SSM agent is there
and if the SSM agent is not there,
we'll use an agentless scanning approach.
The benefit of this approach
is that you can effectively ensure
that you have close to 100% coverage
across all your EC2 instances.
Mainly there could be
operational challenges
with managing an agent or
getting that agent there as well.
In our agent list technology approach,
we use EBS snapshots.
And an important note here
is we'll never take that
data outside of your account,
which could be a compliance
concern for certain customers.
So again, if you're gonna take one thing
out of this talk in terms of turning on
EC2 scanning for Inspector, use hybrid.
It's really simple to set up.
I'm gonna show you that in the demo
and you should get full coverage
across all your EC2 instances.
Oops, go back.
I just want to touch on
a couple other points
about EC2 scanning for Inspector.
The first is that Amazon Inspector
has network reachability analysis.
So it uses automated reasoning
to actually determine whether or not a VM
or an EC2 instance is
reachable via the internet.
This is an important indicator
because that's gonna help
you prioritize those findings
that are generated in Inspector.
We use the network reachability score
based on our analysis
to actually inform the
Amazon Inspector score,
which is our proprietary scoring
that takes the base score from the vendors
and our vulnerability
intelligence information.
And then it overlays information
like network reachability to
provide you a better indicator
of the actual security risk
for that specific finding
on that specific EC2 instance.
The next capability is
Linux deep inspection.
So as a customer within an account
or as operating as the
delegated administrator,
you have the ability
to specify custom paths
that SSM or Inspector
will go ahead and analyze
and look for software vulnerabilities
as well as application programming
package vulnerabilities
for those specific paths.
So if there's a specific structure
that you have in place for your developers
or the people managing
your infrastructure,
you can tell them
or you can configure Inspector
to go scan those paths specifically.
An Inspector will do its job
and it'll actually provide a higher volume
of findings for those paths.
So I return to my map,
we'll move on to the next capability,
which is Lambda scanning.
Here, I present a table
and I'll just talk through
more or less how Lambda scanning works.
So Lambda scanning has
essentially two modes.
The first is Lambda standard scanning,
which is scanning
for package vulnerabilities.
And the second is code scanning,
which is scanning for
application code vulnerabilities.
As a customer, you'll have the ability
to either turn on standard
scanning for an account
or standard and code scanning
for a specific account.
So you can't have code scanning
without standard scanning.
And standard scanning
is gonna work similarly
to VM scanning where we're
looking at those packages
and we are cutting
findings for those CVEs.
Code scanning is actually gonna analyze
that code and it's gonna look
for things like injection flaws,
data disclosure or weak cryptography.
As Rick mentioned with our
continuous scanning approach,
we're gonna be scanning
when new resources,
or in this case functions are detected,
new versions are published of the Lambdas,
or when we have new
information in our database
that tells us that we should reevaluate
those Lambda functions.
From a remediation perspective
for standard scanning
package vulnerabilities,
we're gonna go ahead and tell you
what package you should upgrade to.
That's pretty standard.
But for code scanning,
we're actually gonna highlight to you
what the vulnerable lines of
code are specifically in red.
And then we're gonna give you
basically an AI generated snippet
of how you can adjust that code
to make that more secure.
The third main resource type
that Inspector scans for
are elastic container registry images.
So Inspectors actually scanning images
and not running containers.
And I'll talk a little bit about
how we can help you sort of bridge the gap
between how you're actually
leveraging containers
versus what Inspectors providing you.
And I'll get into some of the
details about how this works.
So as a customer, ECR
actually out of the box.
You can turn on Inspector basic scanning
and that's gonna scan OS vulnerabilities,
operating system vulnerabilities only.
And it will also scan those images
when they're pushed into the repository.
So that's an on-push action only.
So this effectively
does not have continuous
real-time monitoring
and we provide some light
vulnerability intelligence
about those OS vulnerabilities
when we do cut those findings,
which are then visible in Inspector.
Now enhanced ECR image scanning
is basically our
Inspector level capability
of continuous ECR image scanning
that's gonna scan OS vulnerabilities
and programming language packages.
As a customer, we are gonna scan,
you can configure it to scan on push,
but you also have the ability
to control which images you wanna monitor
based on their pull or
their last in use state.
So the reason why this
is important to know
in terms of just how you're
setting up and using Inspector
is that you're not gonna
wanna necessarily scan
every single image in the repository.
That may be a operational
challenge for you to manage that,
but you can use these settings
to control which images are
actually getting scanned
based on those dates and those metrics.
These are the knobs
that you have to control
the volumes of those findings.
And then in terms of enhanced standing,
we're also just providing
the full suite of vulnerability
intelligence like we do
for all the other continuous
monitoring capabilities.
And I wanna touch on
a few other components
of ECR image scanning.
The first is that earlier this year
we launched a feature that enables you
to map the image to running containers.
So we're actually looking at EKS
and ECS information to
tell you how many pods
or containers are
running a specific image.
The reason why this is important
is because as a customer,
if you have a finding or a
variety of critical findings
on a specific image,
you may or may not wanna
prioritize those findings
based on the number of containers
that are actually using the images, right?
So that level of visibility
is gonna help you prioritize
and in the demo in a few minutes,
I'll show you what that
looks like in the console.
Lastly, just a call out,
we're always expanding the
ecosystems that we're scanning
and we're we're generating
vulnerabilities for.
So just a few examples, WordPress, Tomcat.
We continue to expand on this
and we do that based on
customer demand as well.
The last things I want to cover
are essentially some of
the ad hoc functionality
related to additional utility capabilities
that we provide you as a
customer for Inspector.
So just take a step back, I walked through
some of those continuous
scanning capabilities
as a customer.
You can change some of
those settings to control
how you're actually using
Inspector to meet those use cases.
But we also provide some other
capabilities that you can use
as part of your effective
vulnerability management strategy.
The first of these is I'm loosely
referring to as manage SBOM,
but as Rick mentioned,
you can have the ability
to basically export an SBOM
that Amazon Inspector is detecting
because we're actually
monitoring those resources
and near real time you have
the ability to export those,
but you also have the ability
to use our scan SBOM API,
which takes an SBOM as an input
and then generates findings in Inspector
based on that actual SBOM.
So that that's really the
evaluation of the SBOM,
but you can make that API call yourself
and that can give you some flexibility
in terms of how you use the intelligence
and the capabilities of Amazon Inspector.
The SBOMs are in
CyclingDx and SPDX format.
The second capability is CIS
benchmark scanning for EC2.
So you can execute ad hoc
or schedule scanning of
EC2 against EC2 instances.
You can use tags on this.
So this is not quite as real time
as our other capabilities,
but in terms of this
use case that we believe
that that meets the customer needs,
you can view those results.
Certain customers in certain industries
are gonna need this more than others,
but again, this is a piece of capability
that you have the ability to use.
And lastly, we have a
few CI/CD integrations.
You can see here, we have
an example with Jenkins,
but you can use popular CI/CD tools
to orchestrate the integration
of the SBOM generation and scan SBOM
to meet use cases like
scanning container images
before you push them to a registry.
So you can use these tools
to bake into your operational
or development process.
And this is part of your
journey to sort of shift left.
It's a taste in our journey to shift left
and we'll be talking more
about that in a few minutes.
So with that I'm gonna
go ahead and show a demo.
We're basically gonna walk
through some of the console
to show you actually where
to go and Inspector to go
and leverage these capabilities
and how to control them.
So this page here is account management.
And as a delegated administrator,
basically what you have the ability to do
is see this giant grid
of all the different
accounts in your organization
and which capabilities are turned on.
And you can granularly control
which ones to turn on or not.
So in this example, you can see
this account when all sixes.
Doesn't have Lambda scanning enabled,
but I was able to just
simply click that, turn on
and activate Lambda
standard and code scanning.
In account management as well,
we have this coverage.
You can see resources
coverage on the left.
That's gonna fire through
some of these screens,
but effectively across
your entire organization
what is every single VM
that's being scanned or not scanned?
And then I can drill in
and see those details about
those resources themselves.
You can see we have the same thing here
with Lambda functions and
also container images.
So we're decorating that information
that you have an understanding
what's actually being covered and not.
The key point there
being you cannot manage
what you cannot see.
And then we just have some
other information here
in the console showing
like why is something not being scanned
that would be relevant to understand
from a security perspective
or if you're reporting to your managers.
You can see here also I'm just firing
through the SBOM export.
So Inspector is continuously
monitoring all those resources
and you have the ability to simply decide
which resources to generate
the export, the SBOM for.
And then you can put
that in S3 bucket or not.
This page here is our
EC2 scanning setting.
Simply enough, I talk
about the hybrid mode
versus the agent base mode,
but it's easy enough to
just go to the console,
click the EC2 scanning settings
and then turn on hybrid scanning.
At that point, Inspector is
gonna start doing the work
to detect all those other resources
and use our agent list technology.
And then the last real knob
you have, which I talked about,
is a major piece of control
for container image scanning.
You have the ability to determine
when a image is going to be re-scanned
or enter scanning eligibility.
And you can do this by either
choosing elastin use date
or a last pull date, plus a push date.
So you can use those dates
to control the images
that are eligible for scanning.
And lastly, I'm just showing here
the vulnerability database search.
So we're decorating the findings
with the information is here,
but if any time you want to go
to your research about a specific CVE,
you can simply type that in.
We'll provide all the information
here about the finding
as well as any other
intelligence that we have
to help you understand more
about that vulnerability.
So this will be a quick minute demo.
I'm gonna show you what
the container image
to container mapping capability is.
You can see here I drilled
into some critical findings
for container images
or I'm here in the dashboard,
I drilled into some of the findings
for this particular image.
I'm here on the container image.
You can see I have a variety
of findings here, many findings.
I can go view those findings
if that makes sense.
So I have visibility into
what those findings are
for this specific resource.
And then you can see
here there's a hyperlink
to the deployed ECS/EKS tasks and pods.
I can see that workload name there
and then I can simply just
go click into that workload
and explore all the details about that
where I'm actually using
that, which is in ECR itself.
Okay, so I gave a quick overview
on basically how to use Inspector
to meet some of those use cases.
There's plenty of additional
content to help you do that.
More or less you want to
be able to set up Inspector
to start doing that scanning
and play with the knobs
as an administrator,
how to actually use Inspector
to start that vulnerability detection.
And with that, I'll pass it to Nirali.
- Thank you.
Thank you, Anthony.
Okay, moving on.
How many developers here in the audience?
A few?
Good, oh actually more than a few.
I like to start talking
about code security
from the perspective
of this iceberg image.
What we talked so far in our journey
was the tip of the iceberg.
Everything that a security person
gets to see when their workloads
or images are running in production.
Oftentimes it is harder to patch these
running environment
workloads in production.
The challenges become that's visible,
which is underneath the surface,
basically under the water.
Our developers are iterating writing codes
on a daily basis with a
sprint to make changes.
Oftentimes not knowing what
security vulnerabilities
or exposures that they may run into.
Let's take an example.
Business wants a brand new feature
that's gonna change the world.
Product managers and business owners
are working on defining it.
Your customers are
eagerly waiting for that.
Developers have actually
worked weeks and weeks
trying to write code to
get that ready for launch.
Monday morning, the launch is set to go.
And before you hit the green button,
you discover a new critical vulnerability.
You're now faced a decision point.
What do you do?
Do you actually hit the
button and launch it?
Or do you actually scale back,
go back, fix the vulnerability
and delay the launch?
How many of us have actually
run into that scenario
where you've had to make
that decision, right?
Sounds familiar?
I wish there was a way for
developers to know earlier
that hey, what I'm writing
has these vulnerabilities,
has these critical vulnerabilities
so I don't have to wait
all the way till Monday
or Saturday or Sunday to
to discover them, right?
That's what code security is doing.
Throwing light underneath
that water surface
to be able to catch things earlier.
Their production workloads
have vulnerabilities.
You have to patch them with
high urgency obviously.
But what's below the
surface is all the code
that your developer's writing,
all the dependencies
with open source packages
that they may have, that
may have vulnerabilities
that you may not be aware of.
And your infrastructure as code, right?
Like I'm writing code to
scale my infrastructure
and I want them to be secure
before I actually go ahead
and scale up my infra in production.
And we started the journey with Inspector
all the way to the right
where we started to monitor everything
right from the EC2
instances, Lambda functions,
the images that are used to
bring up your pods and tasks.
We introduced an ability
to actually build and test
with your CI/CD pipeline,
but you told us that's not enough.
The same iceberg analogy.
It's not enough.
You have to start catching these early.
It's very expensive.
And to patch and fix these
vulnerabilities in production,
oftentimes you cannot even touch it.
And you own that risk.
And we wanna actually
allow you to balance it.
So we're further shifting left
based on the feedback that you told us.
Let me give you an example
why it's important.
How many of us here know
about Log4J or Log4Shell?
Very good.
To your surprise,
the graph actually shows the downloads
of vulnerable Log4J since January of 2021.
If you see this scaling up even today,
it's been around for four plus years.
It was detected in December
and of December the previous
year, even till date,
30% of the downloads that
happen are vulnerable.
And oftentimes we push
that code to production
and we now have to go and
patch it as security owners.
So it's very important to
catch this early enough
where we don't need to worry about fixing
and patching things in production.
And that's the reason why
we further shifted left
in the development cycle
to catch vulnerabilities
not only in your third party dependencies
of open source packages the
developers are using or pulling,
but also your first party code,
which is like your propriety
code that you're running.
So scanning right where your developers
are working and iterating on your code
with native integration into GitHub
as well as GitLab repositories.
It's very expensive and costly
to actually find these
defects further right.
And so we're shifting as left as we can
to meet your developers
and allow them to do security
right from the beginning.
What is part of code security
and what are we gonna scan?
So we'll integrate with
your GitHub and GitLab.
We will go ahead and
expand our capabilities.
Inspector natively does third-party
and open-source package dependencies
to detect vulnerabilities
in your compute environment.
So we're expanding the same capability.
The software composition
analysis further left.
So in your GitHub or GitLab repositories,
if your developer is using third-party
or open-source packages
that they're pulled into your code base,
we'll scan them to detect
vulnerabilities early
as they write and iterate the code.
But we understand that even
though 80% of your code
may still be open source
and your source code analysis important,
we still have proprietary
first party code that we write
and it's important to scan that as well.
So we are expanding the capability
from not just supply
chain or SCA capability,
we're also adding static
application security testing scan,
which is scanning for
security vulnerabilities
in your first party code as well.
And then, we all typically
use infrastructure as code
to scale our environment,
making sure that the IaC
configurations and my files
are secure inherently
before I use to scale
my cloud environment is very important.
So no different than scanning
the rest of your repository.
We will also scan your IaC files.
Terraform CDK will also be scanned
using the same mechanism
to find security flaws
such as hard coded secrets
and other detectors built into it.
Now we often talk about security person
or persona wanting to
implement guardrails.
But from a developer persona,
it is very difficult to
kind of follow through
and always adhere to those guardrails.
And oftentimes it comes late in the system
where a developer is
mad at a security person
to get that finding generated
a lot later in the system, right?
We talk about DevSecOps,
it's been around for a very long time,
but in reality, it's
very hard to implement
that entire DevSecOps journey
unless you natively embed
and bring the culture in
the developer's workflows.
So with code security,
we're adding an improved governance model.
And what do I mean by that, right?
Like typically a developer
will work in its own environment,
write code, go through the sprint
and at the tail end of the sprint,
we'll get to know about
the vulnerabilities.
There'll be a bunch of back and forth,
we'll have to go fix,
negotiate with the security person,
fix the critical ones,
and then move on.
But what if I told you
that with this capability,
we are gonna change the governance model
where we're natively embedding
security within the workflows
of the developer tools without
them having to switch tools
or even go to the security persona
to look at what the findings are.
So instead of the developers
having full freedom to
just iterate the code
but then find out later
and slow them down,
we wanna give them incremental information
as they're doing PRs, as
they're merging code back
to the main to show them that hey,
here are your top vulnerabilities,
let's go fix them.
Give them guidance of here's
what I recommend your fixes
to be as well as you write the code
and here's the guardrail defined
so that we can build a culture
where security is not a blocker,
but an enabler for allowing developers
to write code fast,
be agile with security in their mindset
and write secure code
right from the beginning.
All of this can be set
by a security persona
to set and define the guardrails
for what your code should look like
before you actually merge into main
or before you actually go to production.
And within those guardrails,
your developer now have unvetted freedom
to quickly treat the
code, learn, fail fast
and improve so that overall
the business has agility,
able to launch features
faster in a secure manner,
and you're actually de-risking
your entire development lifecycle.
The other thing that was very important
that we touched upon
is you have to meet them where they are.
The challenge with some other
code security capability
was security persona wants to go ahead
and build out guardrails,
build out visibility
into the code repository,
but the only way to look at it
was to come into a security
per persona's view.
So you'd have to, hypothetically,
come into Inspector
to see what the vulnerabilities look like.
And developers often
don't wanna switch tools,
like I'm writing code
in my IDE environment,
I pushed it to my code
repository in GitHub
and I'm iterating on GitHub with PRs
and pushing back code into my main branch
and I'm ready to go
and you're asking me
now to switch context,
go and find the vulnerability
somewhere else, right?
So it was very important for us
to have the experience natively embedded
into the workflows where the developer is.
So you have both personas.
If you are a security owner,
you certainly have a centralized
view with an Inspector
to look at all the repositories
that you actually have
or a subset depending on
what's important to you,
such as show me the findings
only for production environment
or anything tagged pink for that matter.
So what's important to you,
you define and you see the vulnerabilities
no different than how you
do with Inspector today.
But if you're a developer,
you do not have to leave
the tools you're using.
Your writing code in your
GitHub as you do PRs,
as you merge the code back in,
you will get to see
all your security
vulnerabilities as comments,
as well as recommendations on
how you would fix the code.
Let's quickly go through a demo.
I promise it's a short
one and the last one.
I'm gonna wear a hat of a developer,
not a very security savvy developer.
I just wanna move fast.
This is my standard Python application.
I have infrastructure as code,
as well as the web application
with builtin vulnerabilities
that I want to show you
and walk you through
in terms of the scenario.
I'm now committing it back
to my GitHub environment.
It's a standard flask application.
It's for demo purposes,
has a bunch of vulnerabilities
as you can see,
application vulnerabilities
as well as infrastructure
as code vulnerabilities
that I wanna walk you
through and identify them
within my setup in Inspector.
As a security person,
the setup is no different
than how you would do it
for the rest of the environment, right?
So you'd come in, set up an integration
depending on what code
repository platform you may have,
you'll go ahead and set up
a configuration integration with GitHub.
In my case, we'll also highlight
all the default configuration settings
that we are recommending, right?
So we're gonna say go ahead
and scan them every time
you're doing a pull request,
pushing back to the main,
you also wanna scan them weekly
and scan across all of it, right?
Scan across your first party code,
third party dependencies,
as well as your infrastructure as code.
By default, go ahead and scan all of it
and create this scan configuration
for you to be able to know
exactly what's happening
in your code repository.
You certainly can filter out
depending on what you may need.
I'm gonna go ahead and
finish the installation.
There is an app that
gets installed natively.
It'll walk you through
that entire workflow.
What the app is actually
doing is allowing,
giving you permissions.
Read/write permissions, so read only
so that I can discover
all the repos and write
so that I can put comments on your PR.
And the write permissions only for PR
so that I can get you comments
from security findings
directly natively into GitHub.
Let's go back to Inspector.
I've now discovered the three repositories
that I actually had in my setup.
We'll go ahead and quickly
look at the findings
from the setup in my web application.
And if you can see, I have
not run any scans right now.
I'll go ahead and initiate
a scan in my repository,
generate the findings.
I'll go ahead and quickly
just run on demand scan
because I set it up for weekly scans
starting Wednesday, today's Monday.
So the next scan will
happen on a Wednesday.
We'll go ahead and set the scan up
to go see the critical findings
that are generated.
Automatically, we'll go ahead
and see the findings on my web app
that I had written poorly
what those findings are.
It was scanned.
I can see the project ID.
It's important so that you know
which project I actually
scan and what the ARN is
and what are the vulnerabilities.
If you notice here I have
restricted IAM policies,
I also have hardcoded secrets
and I have a public read ACL in my repo,
which means I have an S3 bucket
with access publicly
allowed from the outside in.
We'll go ahead and highlight
what the vulnerability is,
when was it actually detected.
This one's package vulnerability.
What are the affected packages,
if it is a code, where exactly in the code
the vulnerability exists as well
and what the recommendations are.
Real quick, I'm gonna
actually make a quick change
on my Terraform file.
I'm gonna add a new feature.
I'm gonna actually commit
it back to the main
and then run another scan
to see if it generates the finding.
And we could do the same on...
we could do the same on PR as well.
If you notice, the scan commit ID changed.
We've generated a new finding,
certainly sort by the age.
The finding generated this time
has the restricted actions
with the principle S3 bucket.
I continue to write bad code
and I get all the findings.
Here are the 15 lines of
code that has an issue
and it was all detected.
Now real quick, let's just see
what happens when I'm
doing a pull request,
I am gonna continue to
write bad code more.
Things I'm gonna add in here.
I'm gonna have a hard coded secret.
I'm also gonna expose
with remote code execution if exploited.
So just bad practice continue to happen.
And when I'm doing that,
what happens when I do a pull request,
the findings actually will
get generated automatically
within the native tool that I have.
And there's a pull request.
I think it's a great code.
I'm excellent, it's good to go.
Let's just do a pull request
and see what happens.
And there are no conflicts.
And I'm gonna start generating
all the findings associated with it.
For me to now realize that the code
that I have written is
actually not very good.
Here are all the hardcoded
secrets that I need to go fix
as well as our remote code
execution, if exploited,
would actually put me at risk
so I can go ahead and make
the changes in the code
while I'm actually doing pull requests.
Just to summarize, we talked
about scheduled scans,
on-demand scans and Git event-based scans
which allows your developers
to actually iterate code securely,
full visibility governance model
that allows them both
to collaborate together.
And with all of that
right from the production workloads
to scanning right in the
beginning at the code repository,
we wanna make the secure
thing the easy thing
for your developers and
your security persona.
So the organizations can
and should build secure software
to get the speed and
agility that we need today.
And just to summarize the same iceberg
with Inspector for
vulnerability management.
We're not only just showing
you what's in production
and the the vulnerabilities
that are available,
but we're also shining
light underneath that.
So you can start early to
understand all your code,
the dependencies infrastructure
as code security vulnerabilities earlier,
fix them in the life cycle.
And then when it comes to security,
it's not just about
vulnerabilities, right?
Like that's one of your problem.
Many of you probably already
are familiar with Security Hub,
like our original Security Hub
is now rebranded as Security Hub CSPM.
We have a new platform for
security finding aggregation
that aggregates findings
from threat findings from GuardDuty,
vulnerability from in Inspector controls
for resources, exposures
and configurations
along with sensitive data from Macie,
all of that together to
have a combined risk score.
We will automatically correlate
these findings for you,
generate a prioritized risk
so that you can take action on
what's more important to you
rather than just looking
at one aspect of risk.
This is a combined
correlated aggregated view.
So you can prioritize take action
based on what's important.
And it already has automated
response capability
built into it for you to do investigation
on all your critical findings.
Lastly, there are additional sessions
to go deeper into Security hub, Inspector,
code security, or AppSec capabilities.
So feel free to just step
into one of these code talks
or breakout sessions or workshops
to get hands on some important blogs
and other useful information on Inspector
if you were curious to learn more.
And you guys have been wonderful audience.
Sorry, you guys have been
a wonderful audience.
So thank you so much.
Please use the app to give us feedback
and would love to learn from you.
Thank you so much,
and we can take questions in
the back if anyone has any.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)